lecturing the world just weeks ago our
prime minister telling the united
nations they must do more when it comes
to the environment it's time for
humanity
to grow up the glasgow cop 26 summit is
the turning point we need all countries
every single one of you
to step up
but what about when it comes to our
trade deals with the rest of the world
an internal document from the department
for international trade leak to sky news
and then retyped by us was sent across
whitehall departments
it said hmg that her majesty's
government should not refuse to
liberalise on products of environmental
concern where there is an economic case
for liberalization or partner interest
is so strong that not doing so would
compromise the wider agreement
that means lowering standards or
liberalizing to boost the economy or get
the deals over the line labor says the
government has got its priorities wrong
it's really shocking to see a document
going around government where they're
essentially saying look
never mind about climate change never
mind about the environment
bolsonaro is a difficult guy if we want
to have a trade deal with brazil
and he wants to sell us stuff from the
rainforest we probably shouldn't get in
the way that much because otherwise you
won't end up with a trade deal
really the trade department says this
does not represent official government
policy but senior tories are worried by
the lack of green goals the government
has already committed to a whole host of
projects in developing countries to
encourage
reforestation we shouldn't at the same
time be allowing other forests to be
chopped down to produce goods
and and
agricultural products to a lesser
standard than we are ourselves we have
to have joined up policymaking across
government
last month sky news revealed britain had
to drop climate change targets from the
australian trade deal at the request of
their prime minister scott morrison
this is the second leak obtained by sky
news raising doubts about the
government's commitment to climate
change in trade deals
the government responds broadly by
shouting fake news
but given that there's concern on all
sides wouldn't they be better off
explaining that trade deals mean big
trade-offs
palm oil from rainforests like this is
currently banned but could be allowed
into the uk in future under this
approach we're talking about products
which are responsible for the decline in
our rainforest for pollution in our
oceans and for the huge impacts of
climate change and those are the kind of
things we should really be ruling out of
trade deals not ruling in
maybe boris johnson has no choice but to
lower standards if he wants trade deals
but he doesn't like discussing
trade-offs in public leaving others to
point the finger sam coats sky news